but the U.S condemned the latest
launches saying they violate U.N
resolutions and are a regional and
international threat well Rob McBride
joins us live now from the South Korean
capital saw Rob so yet more missile
launches uh by North Korea what more can
you tell us
yeah this flurry of missile activity
seems to be continuing the two
short-range ballistic missiles detected
first light on Thursday being fired from
an area of Samsung which is close to
Pyongyang now according to South Korean
military officials it's the first time
that missiles have been detected from
this area so the suspicion is that they
were launched from mobile launchers so
there seems to be North Korea again
developing and illustrating its ability
to deploy and launch missiles relatively
quickly wherever it chooses uh One Flew
350 kilometers the second one flew 800
kilometers Landing in the seas that
separate the Korean Peninsula from Japan
and all of this comes of course as we
have these heightened tensions with this
escalation since Tuesday's launch of
this intermediate missile by North Korea
over the top of Japan which then I saw a
response from South Korean and U.S
forces firing their own missiles and
organizing their own air drills and now
the redeployment of the Ronald Reagan
strike group this aircraft carrier in
Korean waters for the first time in five
years now being redeployed back to these
Waters again and Rob what sort of
reaction have we had then from both
North and South Korea to this escalation
yeah there's been a tough reaction from
South Korea saying that this is a
serious provocation the South Korean
president is saying that he accepts this
is a very worrying time for people in
South Korea but vowing to protect the uh
the nation he says condemning this
action by North Korea and also making
the point that it's Tuesday's
intermediate missile launch of 4500
kilometers way over uh Japan Japan into
the Pacific Ocean actually puts the U.S
territory of Guam this uh island in the
Western Pacific within range with its a
very important U.S and military bases so
making reference back to 2017 when the
North Korea have threatened the island
of Guam when tensions were really at the
the worst that they have been in a
number of decades for its uh part the
North Koreans strangely have not made
any reference to this uh intermediate
range uh missile launch on Tuesday but
instead has and the U.S for redeploying
the strike group the aircraft carrier
back to Korean Waters saying that its
actions have just been countermeasures
to what it says have been provocations
from the US and its allies all right uh
Robert McBride Live Australian Seoul Rob
thank you